crazy group of humans that came oh I
always want you to do the impersonation
for me when Italian people in Jersey
found out that Marlon Brando is gay
I can't [ __ ] believe it
twenty years he was the Godfather and no
no no he couldn't blow a regular dude no
god forbid he blows a black dude to
really stab me right here in the [ __ ]
heart I couldn't even take him no more I
had to throw the DVD collection away the
[ __ ] I would love to hear one of
those guys what they said when they
found out that that week didn't they say
that he [ __ ] everybody men and women
oh yeah he banged everybody [ __ ]
everybody and then it came out he was
banging the guy with the big dick and
cube that's right Superman
that's so [ __ ] poor Italian people
were there with Godfather fans they were
lighting those [ __ ] DVDs on fire [ __ ]
Marlon Brando
poor poor homophobes I like more now
yeah listen
me Richard Pryor thinking about Richard
Pryor getting so coked up that he let
Marlon Brando [ __ ] was one of the
things I was like unless he luck that's
prejudice with me I should just assume
he enjoyed it and assume he enjoyed
having sex while I'm brave why should I
give a [ __ ]
remember one thing cuz you're gonna die
will that tell you this uh-oh Marlon
Brando taught at the studio and - giving
them like a hundred grand to read super
minute but you know when people call you
up Joe hi Joe this is Cynthia from your
engines right we're sending you a script
over fee to approve to read give me a
hundred grand I'll reduce it but he went
to the island he went deep and he
believed his ego you gotta remember that
was an all-time record for a long time
well he got four Superman he banged him
out he took him to the cleanest time
[ __ ] him he [ __ ] him up in the ass bad
my big money find out what they pay them
in nineteen seven
whatever for Superman amendment he
[ __ ] them big time
I think it's mutiny on the bounty I'm
one of those movies they kept saying it
no we have a beautiful spot for you
right here and the marina though right
if we do this we had to do this on this
island I found he had gone down in from
love he made the studio shoot down and
then and then we went down there who
wants to go to [ __ ] whatever Island
they shot that so that's where he lived
right so he went down there he got down
and he's like Jamie what's your job PA
no more you the director rugged you're
this and everybody was shooting and they
were shooting his feet
they were shooting like him running and
like the shore and meanwhile he's just
banging [ __ ] Hawaiian women eight at
a time or do you Bagon kids all those
kids that shot themselves all those kids
he had no my gun all those poor kids
that [ __ ] God rest their souls and
all those problems yet he was down there
like [ __ ] just matador whoever
paramount
whoever the network was showed up down
and so let's see the dailies and I said
what the [ __ ] is this you're done they
brought somebody else in Marlon ended up
saying [ __ ] I body out of it he
bought the island didn't he like this is
just crazy [ __ ] iron over the years and
they just lived on the island and then
if they wanted they had a quality island
and they had like levels all you want me
to read the script that's gonna cost you
oh you want me to come to the studio
that's 300,000 he had levels of [ __ ]
and they would give it to him they would
and then they didn't want him for the
Godfather
they were like nah there's no way we
want that [ __ ] guy Wow and then
finally he put the tape in his mouth and
all that [ __ ] and they approved him he
did a brother that movies like a pawn
the one he did that last tango in Paris
is it that's like a light porn and then
the chick came out years later said that
[ __ ] don't call rape me yeah he
was the king of me too he invented me
through that [ __ ] dawg
oh yeah she came out years later and
said something about he she didn't know
what would mom would brand no one in
there and choked her out like McQueen
and [ __ ] and the getaway she thought
she was just getting pushed you have the
McQueen and who was it with Wow Emma
girl you gras that was hard to watch
dude cuz you could tell that was real
there's no way that wasn't real like he
was really hitting her yeah no no he was
a method actor [ __ ] it's harsh he's
crazy
you got crazy that scene was so real
because of it I mean it's awful to watch
but but it's real right it's an awful
scene it's real [ __ ] man that you
imagine being her and all sudden the
dude just starts smacking you in the
head for real you don't know what to do
and you don't want to bail out of the
scene you're getting [ __ ] up though
he's [ __ ] you up and she didn't stop
she just kept saying the lines and
working with it [ __ ] dude
Jesus Christ what do you say to somebody
after that like a man I'm sorry but
that's what the scene call for you can't
see peep it sounds [ __ ] up to say but
I think even just that recent a time
people did not understand that if you're
smacking people in the head like that
you're giving them [ __ ] brain damage
like you smack someone in the head like
that like you could seriously [ __ ] them
up like something could be wrong with
them for a long time even if they don't
go unconscious